what I learned from David Sinclair
there's two um substances that you can
take which I've been using for the last
year so since I started watching some of
those podcasts because I started going
in this Rabbit Hole asleep and then I
started watching like anti-aging
podcasts and stuff that came out of that
and there's two common uh elements that
seem widely agreed upon by you know like
the community out there that deals with
the anti-agent the doctors the experts
you know the hubermans of the world and
all that sort of stuff and it seems like
Resveratrol and nmn uh you get them both
in pill form it's just N is a Norman m
is in Mark and and as a Norman again
um it was the other compound and it's
nice that I'm in blah blah or something
like that I'll obviously mispronounce it
so I'll just give you guys the acronym
and um and
um and resveratal is the other one which
I probably pronounce incorrectly as well
but those two things are highly
recommended by the community and they uh
seem to work so
um that's the first thing that I would
recommend you taking a look at now
you can pop as many pills as you want
supplements and all this sort of stuff
um and some of them can be effective and
some of them are not very effective and
some are effective for some people and
not effective for other people sort of
thing but before you start getting into
supplementation and just doing like
Cookie Cutter okay I'm going to take a
protein powder okay I'm going to take a
a vitamin D product and a vitamin C
product sort of thing like to
incorporate into my lifestyle choices
because I think that's what I need but
before you start going and doing that
I'm going to take you down a deep Rabbit
Hole of what does work very well and
what I've been doing and I know for a
fact uh the results that I'm getting out
of it are very very positive so what I'm
going to give you guys tonight is going
to be very useful so pay attention
um the link to call in and ask questions
will be available halfway through the
show or so uh moths being gonna be in
the Green Room make sure your audio and
everything is up to par and uh let's get
right into this so the next thing is
you
should definitely get your DNA analyzed
and for some people that might sound
weird
some a lot of stuff that I'm going to
talk to you guys about tonight's going
to be like well that's just too weird
I'm just going to drink my Bud Light and
sit here and that'll be all and that's
cool too
um
so
this is the result of my DNA
um
assessment and Dr Anthony J is somebody
I've had in the podcast twice now so if
you're unfamiliar with him he wrote a
book called estrogeneration The subtitle
is uh how estrogenics are essentially
making you fat sicken and fertile
and he um he's well researched he did
his PhD on cholesterol did another one
on hormones so definitely knows what
he's talking about and I was introduced
to him through a mutual friend and what
you do is you basically get your raw DNA
code through 23andMe
which isn't expensive it's around 100
bucks I don't know what the total cost
is today but they always have coupons
floating around for black Fridays and
stuff like that if you want to wait for
it but it's not going to cost you a lot
of money so let's just start with that
um and what it does is these are the
colorful charts that they do and you
know people are all like oh look you
know I'm 27 you know Hasidic Jew and 13
uh Palestinian and you know 37 percent
uh East Asian or Mongolian or something
like you know there's all these these
these like breakdowns which people think
are all pretty and all that sort of
stuff and they're like I know my
background now I know my ancestry and
that's just the tip of the iceberg it's
it's really useless information at that
point but what you can do is you can
download the code from their website and
it and it gives you all the genetic code
that you need to give to uh Dr Anthony J
who runs it through his program and then
he has all of your DNA assessed and it
tells you where your deficiencies are
your strengths don't really matter it's
like if you have really good bones
awesome you know if you have really good
muscle fiber uh great you know sort of
thing so a lot of this stuff here
and I did a full breakdown so if you're
a member of my private Community guys uh
there's a full breakdown that I posted
to zenforo you should go watch it
because the entire conversation I have
with Dr J is there and we go through all
of these line by line explaining them in
extreme detail but what I have here is
the summary and it basically highlights
um
genetic anomalies deficiencies you know
whatever it is that you want to call it
but
um areas of concern is what I would
distill it down to and he can get down
to so I'll just read a few of these off
to you
um he can tell you if you've got the
foxo3 gene which is an uncommon Gene
that gives you a higher likelihood of
living to the age of 100 or higher I
have that so it should be around for a
long time for you guys
um it can tell you if you're prone to
alzheimer's it can tell you uh how you
react to stress and what supplements you
can use if you react difficult lead to
if you have a difficult reaction to to
stress he'll make some recommendations
as far as like
what you can take because you have a a
particularly annoying stress Gene that
reacts very easily
um talk about anxiety you can talk about
how your body metabolizes caffeine
alcohol uh your diabetic uh profile how
prone you are to having diabetes
inflammation in your body what kind of
foods might cause inflammation like
there's a dairy Gene and if you don't
have this Gene then dairy in your body
causes excessive inflammation okay noted
right
um then I'll get into Dairy a little bit
more later on
diabetes uh heart lipid panels so on my
heart level panels you know you can see
some notes I don't know if you can see
the highlights and the notes here but
the lighting doesn't really work anyway
um so there's a lot of detailed
information here and he's telling me you
need to keep an eye on fasted
triglycerides uh tells me what range
that I need to be in you need to keep an
eye on
um the LPA Gene and recommends niacin
taken before Asana interesting
um I haven't Revisited this in a while
so taking the niacin before us on it
helps with the lp little a
um it's a marker in your blood which
indicates that you have a higher
likelihood for heart disease or stroke
or stuff like that uh he also recommends
me to keeping a close eye on
homocysteine so some of these things
were not included in my blood labs when
I was running them before and I
basically take this to my doctor that's
doing my health care and I'm like okay
look you know I've analyzed my DNA
here's some of the blood Labs that he
wants me to keep an eye on so let's add
them to the test okay no problem he
knows who this guy is he's well
researched he takes a look at his site
takes a look at the report looks good to
me right so we add those in there
leaky gut issues what kind of uh you
know if you need to avoid uh gluten
because you know there's some people
that have that gluten intolerance uh
pesticides seed oils
um he'll tell you if he's got um
so there's a uh
plant sterol Gene which is extremely
rare apparently it only exists in
something like less two percent of
people out there but essentially plant
cholesterols was one I wouldn't have
known this my doctor wouldn't have ever
known this anybody running my blood Labs
would have never known this the only
reason why this showed up and I figured
this out was because I did my 23andMe I
had Dr J run the raw code through his
algorithm and we figured out exactly
what my DNA is all about and I have a
rare Gene where I have an issue with
plant cholesterols so I can't metabolize
um a lot of the stuff that I've been
eating actually nuts seeds seed oils
avocados olive oil anything that's a
fatty plant I can't have
um and it just bungs up my system and it
causes inflammation and it affects your
hormones right I mean potentially I
might have been able to have avoided trt
if we had caught this before I was 40
and did something about it back then but
I cut it after the fact that I'm already
you know year years in a trt so it's not
like you can come off and change that
right now but plant cholesterols
apparently can have a deleterious effect
on your hormone panel and have you can
have issues with testosterone production
High conversions to estrogen all that
sort of stuff so these are all things
that you can only discover if you have
your DNA fully analyzed uh bilirubin
levels you want to I need to keep an eye
on those and I need to use a UV light if
they get too low all kinds of stuff
wicked wicked information so you that
would be that would be a definite must
do the cost is not that much or 23andMe
like I said it's around 100 bucks he'll
analyze your
um DNA raw code uh print out everything
for you or email it to you and spend an
hour and a half so 90 minutes with you
on Skype and I think it's like 400 bucks
that is a [__] steal for 500 bucks
you can get everything that you need to
know about your genetic
issues and opportunities to correct
lifestyle
um you'll sleep better you'll you'll
you'll put on muscle easier you'll lose
fat easier you know like you'll you'll
do everything better when your body's
optimized so that would be the first
recommendation that I have very very
high up on the list not that expensive
and exceptionally exceptionally useful I
found a ton of value out of going uh
through this and I've Incorporated it
um in my day to day
next thing
um so let's make a Health Report file
over here
blood Labs uh
here we go
the food intolerance test this is the
other one so
these are called MRT tests in the states
um the Canadian Blood Lab office that I
use is dynacare and they don't have the
MRT test but they have an equivalency
test which is apparently almost as good
but
uh these they're about 300 bucks I get
my labs run every quarter usually
anywhere from four to six months I mean
the last one I did was six months ago so
um sorry the longest span that I had
between them was about six months so
this one over here reveals exactly what
you have a intolerance to and that
doesn't mean that you can't eat it or
you can't consume it it just means that
it doesn't cooperate real well with your
gut biome with your genetic code with
how you are so all they do is when they
take your blood then I mean there's an
explanation I don't know if it's on this
page uh dealing with antibodies I
believe is what it does so food
allergies produce hang on a sec
right sorry up here food intolerance is
not the same as a food allergy allergic
reactions are classified as type 1
hypersensitivity and involve a substance
in your body called ige antibodies which
are different from the IGG antibodies
involved in food intolerance
food allergies produce an immediate
reaction after you eat the food for
example peanuts and shellfish anybody's
got those extreme allergies pretty much
die after eating them symptoms can
include rash and sneezing difficulty
breathing and even life-threatening due
to strong with spots called
anaphylaxis food intolerance reactions
are classified as type 3
hypersensitivity and they can confirm
sorry and they can occur within hours or
days after consuming the food so that's
the difference between an intolerance
and an allergy and this tests for
intolerances so basically if you put
this stuff in your body inflammation
Rises and it causes your body to work
harder than what it needs to to process
those calories
um
so right at the top for most people will
be Dairy and it's right up there for me
uh egg whites they say the reason why
most people have an intolerance to egg
whites is because they use the I think
it's called the albuminum or something
like that I'm totally pronouncing it
wrong but it's that like
um film like when you hard boiled an egg
and you crack the shell that's like that
film that sometimes is in the way it's
that nasty film
um they use that with um
vaccines to create you know certain
vaccines so
um because the vaccines designed for
your body to fight whatever you know it
it sends in your body you tend to have
the same reaction with that part of the
egg
um apparently as you get older so it's
just weird [__] but um yeah anyway so
it'll identify a bunch of stuff that
you've got intolerances to and you just
take it out of your diet and see what
happens and the biggest difference is
that I noticed is bloating went down a
lot for me and so did
um gas like I used to fart a lot I'll be
honest and as soon as I did this test
and I and I took out like the top like
there's basically three sections there's
orange uh blue and then there's like
basically nothing which is a green area
meaning like eat as much as of it you
know as you want
um and if you take out like basically
the top orange ones which are the ones
that are creating the most
um issues you know for your body
holy smokes what a difference man
um again these this test is not that
expensive
um it's called a food intolerance test
and there's 200 plus metrics on this one
they have a cheaper one which has 150 I
think or a little bit less and
what do they cost I'm trying to remember
the cost it's like 300 bucks maybe 350.
um it's only a few hundred bucks and it
tests your blood up against these
antibodies to see what kind of
intolerance exist in your body to these
certain uh foods and you just take them
out of your diet and it's not like you
have to stop eating them like I haven't
completely stopped with dairy I still
put cream in my coffee just a little bit
and I'll have ice cream from time to
time but very very rarely but when I do
farting comes back right so you know
it's just a it's a small minor change
but it makes a huge difference in my
opinion I got a few more here but before
I continue with those I'm going to drop
the
uh stream yard link and just pin it up
at the top it looks like moff's already
done it
yeah so just pin that up at the top and
if you guys want to uh participate in
the Q a you have to watch live and you
have to be on YouTube watching live
because that's where you get the link
uh next one
blood Labs anyways we'll talk about
blood so I had this conversation with my
dad the other day you know it was
Father's day yesterday so happy belated
Father's Day to all the uh the men out
there uh doing that difficult job
and he had his Labs with him and he's
like Rich you know a lot about this
stuff come sit with me and explain this
and I'm like okay fine you know let's
see what the labs say
um so I can log in with my phone and get
my data here and I think with his when I
counted it
he had only like 10 lines
and the lines that he had that this
doctor and his doctor you know did the
standard oh yeah everything's fine you
know it's within range you know stuff
um and my dad's like yeah I'm always
lethargic I'm super tired I don't know
what's wrong
anyway they got him on all kinds of like
cholesterol meds and stuff like that and
it puts all of your cholesterol levels
down in the basement and most people
don't know this but your hormones are
made from cholesterol so that's probably
why he's so lethargic that and he's
probably got low T because if you have
low cholesterol then you're not going to
make any tea so your testosterone is
going to go down
um so I'm looking at mine here and I and
I usually get anywhere from 64 line
items up to 75 depending on what my
doctor is running
my dad only got 10 and I'll tell you why
he only got 10. It's because he's going
to the free health care clinics right
the family doctor the Jack of all trades
the guy that doesn't really give a [__]
but let's be honest the guy that I deal
with and
don't ask me for his contact information
because I'm because I'm really going to
sell them up here because he's because
he's already busy the only people I give
his contact information to or guys in my
community that live in the area that's
it but
he like he is so he's so thorough and
he's and he's partnered with a um guy
that's basically a lifelong biohacker
he's like in his 60s in phenomenal shape
former competitive bodybuilder judge
bodybuilding shows uh in excellent shape
knows how to deal with men and women's
hormone panels all this stuff the guy
knows stuff like like these are the
people that you want to deal with when
it comes to managing your health as you
get older you go to the general
practitioner you go to the grocery store
and you put like the [__] that's in the
freezers and the cans and the packaging
stuff full of preservatives in your bug
you take it home and you eat that and
you don't take it take a good look at
your blood Labs I guarantee it's it's a
uh it's not only going to shorten your
life which doesn't really matter but the
quality of your life is going to go down
as well right like I'd rather have
80 years of quality life than 110 years
of this fox 03 gene or whatever it is
that I have you know makes me lift over
100 in like a miserable shape I'd rather
be fully optimized and live less right
so
the point that I'm getting at is your
blood labs are incredibly important I
talked about it in a a chapter in my
book in the unplugged Alpha and I broke
down exactly
in that chapter which by the way is
going to have some new information and
in the follow book too
um exactly how trt Works how how the how
the hormone uh clinics work and all this
sort of stuff but you need to find not
just the Jack of all not just like if
you go to one of these places and and
they run 10 15 you know uh line items on
your blood labs and they go okay well
let's just give them a little script
here for some DHEA and give them a
script for some testosterone and give
them a little script for some HCG and
then send them off on his way oh wait
hang on a sec come back let's let's give
you a AI as well to make sure that your
estrogen doesn't doesn't go too high now
go away
and if you're not measuring those up
against your blood Labs your your DNA
your genetics your uh food sensitivities
right like if you're not optimizing in
every area then there's holes it's like
swiss cheese right yeah it's cheese yeah
you can eat it but it's got holes
everywhere right
um I don't like that
I'm at the stage where it's like I want
to be thorough with this stuff I want to
get good results out of it I want to
look at like I look around at some
people and they're like 10 15 sometimes
even 20 years younger I mean and they
look like [__] like
completely out of shape man boobs you
know just
they can do a lot better and I know that
it's hard because nobody has given this
information it's not it's not clear it's
not concise you often have to go looking
for it I went looking for a lot of this
stuff because I had bad sleep at one
time and I have a video
on this podcast list talking about sleep
and everything I did to improve that so
that's another story but I'll keep going
because we got to take some of these
call-ins over here
um so we got the food sensitivity test
which is also called the MRI MRT test in
the U.S uh blood Labs make sure you get
detailed blood Labs look at everything
liver kidney do a urine test do
um your minerals do heavy metals you
know check and see if you have mercury
you know
um a lot of people don't know this but
if you eat seafood you will have high
levels of mercury
um I found out because
my doctor was like well something's off
here and I said well hang on a sec when
was it like we worked together on this
stuff and I'm smart enough to ask
questions because I because I've read up
on a lot of [__] and I've watched a lot
of podcast interviews and I said to him
I go
we haven't checked Mercury yet I go
run a Mercury test and let's see what
comes back you know the lap so we go
about Mercury Sky High and he goes well
what are you eating and I said well you
wanted me to increase my protein because
I also trained with this guy too by the
way he's my personal trainer and he goes
you know I wanted you to eat more
protein I go so I did and one of the
things I like to eat that's you know uh
animal protein is tuna so I was eating a
shitload of tuna probably at least one
serving of tuna per day some days maybe
two uh tuna out of a can tuna poke you
know from the freezer which is basically
raw tuna it's like sushi great type of
tuna
um so he's eating a lot of tuna he's
like that's it it's a tuna any old fish
from the ocean is going to have very
high levels of Mercury right
so salmon he said is pretty much is
pretty safe because they're young fish
they you know they spawn every year they
get a new one every year sort of thing
so they're not they're not swimming
around for 15 years eating up all the
[__] in the ocean and Mercury's you know
collecting in their body
um so these are things that again you
know you have to consider you know you
have to take a look at and it's like
okay well how do you get the Mercury out
of your system now because that now
that's just saturated in your body and
it's not good for you uh there's all
kinds of Downstream effects yeah you
know brain fog is probably like one of
the biggest ones and one of the biggest
complaints that I've had over the last
couple years right so he's like okay
well
let's go on to the next uh tip and it's
vitamin infusions what are we at we're
at the half hour mark and it's vitamin
infusion so IV infusions
the highest rate of absorption that
you're going to get in a supplement is
in my supplement line over here okay uh
the company that makes these their
biggest obsession is the absorption rate
the only way to get a higher absorption
rate than what's in those caplets is
with the IV infusion that's where they
take the needle and they go right in
your vein they hang the bag up and it
drips and you're sitting there for 45
minutes if you follow me on Instagram
you see sometimes I post
um videos of me doing the IV drip and
what's in the bag and a link usually to
something so you guys can go and
research it for yourself
um but IV infusions can be very helpful
so
I've identified that I've got a Mercury
issue so how the hell do you get out of
your system all right
um you know I asked my doctor he goes
well we can do an IV infusion with
something called EDTA which essentially
removes metals from your body
um they use a lot for people with uh
brain fog you know with heavy metals in
their blood and their organs and stuff
like that and it helps your body
metabolize and get rid of it another
thing you can do is you can sit in the
sauna and sweat it out of your skin
that's another way that your body gets
rid of metals in your bodies you
basically sweat it through your skin
um so I've been doing that you know I've
been doing the sauna I've been doing the
IV infusions with the EDTA there's
another really good one called plaquex
which is another IV infusion uh which
gets rid of any kind of plaque buildup
on your arteries
um so I have a genetic predisposition to
heart disease and you know my dad's side
of the family my dad had a heart attack
when he was in his 60s he had a triple
bypass he's still alive and kicking well
today
um but there's IV infusions that I can
Implement because I go there every week
right it's about 180 bucks per bag way
cheaper again to have vitamins than it
is to the IV infusion but the IV
infusion is a lot more efficient and
your body absorbs pretty much you know
100 of what you're putting in
um so we do plaque X which is great for
removing plaque from your arteries that
has a whole bunch of benefits you know
you get plaque out of any of your blood
vessels that's building up around your
heart and your brain and your organs in
your penis like all of this stuff will
help blood flow better and you'll you
know you'll live better right you'll get
more oxygen all your body parts
everything will work properly when you
want them to work properly
um you know plaque does build up in your
body the older that you get people don't
know this but if you take vitamin D
without a without an mk7 variant of uh
vitamin K then you will move calcium
into your blood vessels which will
create plaque and you know we're always
told to take vitamin D but there's not a
lot of people that pay attention to the
fact you need a d slash uh K variant
which is a a blend that's what mine is
by the way in my lineup and you guys
will see a link to that you know below
at the unpluggedalpha.com you can just
go to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash uh store or supplements just go to
the site you'll see it there
um but these are all things that you
have to contemplate and then of course
you know the third thing is
um just a standard vitamin bag and the
cool thing about the vitamin bag is it's
like an a la carte restaurant like he's
got all of these vials laid out with the
syringes in front of them the bag over
here and you basically have a designer
bag right and you know he's like okay
you know what are we working on because
he's training me he's taking care he's
taking care of my diet
he's like well you know since we're
working on the training part let's get
some amino acids in there we'll get some
citrulline in there we'll get some
Arginine in there that'll increase uh
nitric oxide that'll increase blood flow
um he starts putting some vitamins and
some minerals in there that I'm
deficient in that show the deficiencies
in my blood lab that's the cool thing
about working with a clinic like this
that really knows what the [__] they're
doing it's like I can get my hormone
panel fixed there I can get my training
done there I can get my diet done down
there anything that shows up as a
deficiency in my blood Labs just put it
in the vitamin bag right and it drips in
um
I'll tell you something I've I've
probably never felt better in the last
10 or 15 years and it's only been the
last couple years that I've been doing
this right so it's just something to
contemplate I've mentioned it in passing
before in some videos
um you know what people sometimes call
in and I said that I might do a full
show so this is your full show on it
right this is this is pretty much
everything that I've done that's moved
the bar as far as self-care and helping
you know delay a lot of the um issues
with aging because it's going to happen
to all of us and again if you guys don't
know
how something works
how can you fix it you know that's why I
say it's important you know run your uh
23andMe get your DNA analyzed uh get a
food sensitivity test you know to see
what causes the inflammation in your
body and then manage your blood Labs
accordingly like if you have issues down
the road in your family with Alzheimer's
there's things that you can do to
prevent Al Alzheimer's there really is
if you have issues in your family with
diabetes or you might be prone to
diabetes there's things that you should
be doing to manage and test in your
blood labs to make sure you're not
heading in that direction where you have
to take insulin pins and check your
blood so often all that sort of stuff
these are all really important things to
look at I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out